there are many things that Marvel fans
want right now one of course being The
Avengers 4 trailer but we still have not
found out the Avengers 4 title or have
we there's a rumor going around from a
very credible source that we actually do
know the name of the movie and this
title that is rumored actually lines up
with the Russo brothers very cryptic
message that they posted a couple of
weeks ago real quick if you're new to my
channel I'm doing a giveaway right now
giving away a few copies of Avengers
infinity war on blu-ray or ant-man and
the loss whichever you would like if you
win some special edition posters and
memorabilia all you have to do to enter
the giveaway is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so some things that we know
about the Avengers 4 title is one it's
not in Avengers infinity war it's not
mentioned at all
everyone thought endgame for a really
long time because Doctor Strange said
we're in the end game now and Tony Stark
mentioned in game before as well but
again the Russo brothers have said that
it is not mentioned and in game was
mentioned so it can't be in game another
thing that the Russo brothers said about
the title is that it'll scare us so
there's been a few other titles thrown
out there that make a lot of sense but
aren't so scary and what sort of a title
could really scare you anyways well this
rumored Avengers 4 title could actually
fit the bill according to Jeremy Conrad
at MCU cosmic the title for the
conclusion to Avengers infinity war is
Avengers annihilation according to
Jeremy Conrad this comes from and I
quote him here a source who is most
reliable it fits the bill in a few ways
this was not mentioned in any of the
previous films and it is kind of scary
if you think about it Thanos the mad
Titan succeeded in the snap he wiped out
half of the universe and now they're
going to battle against him again and
let's be honest
did he really even try at the end iron
man barely made him bleed so if we're
talking about the annihilation of the
Avengers
Thanos can certainly make that happen
and again he's already annihilated half
of the people in exist
which also fits the fact that the Russa
brother said that the Avengers for title
would be a spoiler two Avengers infinity
war and if you connected annihilation
with feyo's and the Infinity Gauntlet
you could definitely tell that he would
succeed in collecting the stones and
doing the snap this also continues the
tradition of them naming Avengers movies
after big events in the comics we had
age of Ultron infinity war based off of
the Infinity Gauntlet saga and now
Avengers annihilation so this really
does seem to fit the bill for what the
Avengers for title is supposed to be and
again it comes from a most reliable
source so is this it is this the title I
personally think it is but let me know
what you all think let me know all of
your thoughts and feelings in the
comments below don't forget to subscribe
like and comment below to enter the
giveaway and so you can stay up to date
on everything marvel and Avengers for as
always thank you all so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
you
you